the winner of the first round of costa
rica's elections was expected
ex-president jose maria figueres
the runner-up was not
rodrigo chavez an internationally
recognised economist nevertheless seen
in costa rica as a political upstart
after six months as finance minister in
which he clashed with the outgoing
president
now the two men will head to a runoff
this april for chavez who polled in
fourth place that's already an
achievement
we are going to a second round the new
party the youngest party of this
campaign is going to the second round
but we are leaving behind the conflict
the confrontation
some will struggle to make peace with a
man whom several women accused of sexual
harassment during his more than 20 years
with the world bank he dismissed the
claims as gossip and lies
the man he'll now face in the runoff
drags the weight of his own scandal
behind him costa rica media accused jose
maria figueres of receiving bribes from
a french telecommunication company back
in 2004.
he denies that the case never went to
court and presents himself an
ex-president running with one of the
country's oldest parties as a safe pair
of hands
10 points clear of chavez he's feeling
confident
today costa rica won
not even the pandemic could stop the
civic spirit of our people
of courage and love for our homeland a
responsibility to take our country
forward congratulations costa rica today
we return to shine in the world
but that's painting a very rosy picture
of an election which saw about 40
percent of the electorate declined to
vote that's the highest abstention for a
first round in 70 years
analysts say that's not just due to the
pandemic but a general lack of
enthusiasm for the political options
even as living costs rise and
unemployment stands at 14 percent
now senores figures and chavez will see
who gets the chance to tackle that as
they run again in april john holman al
jazeera